&gt;&gt; We know an ordered pair is always x, and then y. So for this first ordered
pair, I move one unit to the right from the origin, and then two units down. One
unit right, two units down. That's C. For the second one, I move one unit left
of the origin, and then two units down. That must be B. For the third choice, I
have to move two units right, and then one unit down. Two units to the right of
the origin. And then one unit down, so answer choice D. This, of course, leaves
us with the last one, which is A. We move two units left, for negative 2, and
then one unit up. If you got all these right, great work on this quiz. And if
you didn't get all of them right, think about which ones gave you trouble. Keep
in mind which direction you should move first, right or left. And then, up or
down.